ANTONIO FUENTES: Hi, my name is
Antonio Fuentes, and I'm a
product manager at Google.
Part of my job is to make sure
that developers have a great
experience building
applications
that use Google APIs.
Last week, I posted a YouTube
video on the best practices
for using Google APIs and
getting started quickly.
Some of you had questions on
the content of the video.
And I'm here to address some
of those questions.
There's a question on what
happens if credentials you
obtain in the dev console
are leaked.
It says, "What do I do next?"
Credentials leaking is a risk
that any developer can face.
Luckily, the Google APIs Console
makes it easy to deal
with this risk.
If your credentials ever leak,
or you suspect they leak, or
they have leaked, it's
easy to rotate
them in the dev console.
You can create additional keys
in the dev console and roll
them out to your client
application, and then turn the
leak key off whenever you want
without creating a new project
in the dev console.
The next question says, "How
long do OAuth tokens last?
When do they expire?" This
is a good question.
In the video, we went through
the OAuth flow, and how to
obtain access tokens, and how
to obtain refresh tokens.
An access token generally
lasts for an hour.
You can use a refresh token to
request an access token or an
additional access token
at any time.
So keep that in mind.
The good news is that if you
use the Google Client
Libraries, which we also
introduced in the video,
they'll take care of all
of that logic for you.
So they'll exchange refresh
tokens for access tokens when
your access tokens are
ready to expire.
So if you use the client
libraries, you don't even have
to worry about this.
If you're coding on your own
without using the client
libraries, you would have
to refresh your
access every hour.
The next question states, "How
do I know which APIs are
supported by the Discovery
Service?" The best way to do
this is to actually make an
API call to the Discovery
Service or to use the
APIs Explorer.
The APIs Explorer is a tool
that we also introduced in
last week's video.
It will show you all the APIs
that are currently exposed
through the Discovery Service.
You'll notice that some of the
APIs in there have different
methods and have different
resources exposed by the API.
All of that information is
available in the APIs Explorer.
The next question states, "The
only way to hide a link from a
user's goo.gl dashboard is to
click on checkbox and press
'Hide.' Unfortunately, we can't
hide links with the help
of the API.
Could you add some method like
url.hide to the API?" We get
questions like this every
once in a while.
This is a feature request to
the URL Shortener API.
And in my view, it's a
good feature request.
So my recommendation is to go
to the URL Shortener API
documentation, which I can show
you now on the screen.
You can join the discussion
group for the URL Shortener
API and submit a feature
request for that.
Now back to the questions.
The next question states, "Why
do we need different types of
client IDs such as server, web,
and Android?" This is
actually a really
good question.
You noticed on last week's
video that when we obtain
credentials in the Google APIs
Console, the APIs console will
ask us which type
of key we need.
And some of the types available
are for server
applications, for web
applications, or for installed
applications such as
Android and iOS.
Behind the scenes, the OAuth
flow works a little bit
different depending on
the device that your
application runs on.
And this is why the dev console
will ask you in
advance what type
of application
you're dealing with.
This will ensure that your
applications are checked in
the most appropriate way.
So do specify, when you're
asking for credentials in the
dev console, which type
of application
you're working with.
The next question states, "What
happens if I send both
an API key and a client ID
when I make an API call?"
You'll recall from the video
that you can obtain two types
of credentials in
the dev console.
One is API keys and the other
one is client IDs.
And they are a little
bit different.
API keys allow you to make API
calls that don't fetch
end-user data.
For example, a call to
the Translate API.
There's no user data involved
in that transaction, so you
can use an API key.
For other types of calls that
do involve fetching end-user
data, such as a call to the
Google+ API, for example, to
fetch an end user's posts, you
will require a client ID.
It is possible to make an API
key and passing both a client
ID and an API key in the same
call, as the person asking
this question has pointed out.
There's very few situations in
which you want to do this.
And I'll show you some of those
on the screen right now.
When you go to the Google APIs
Console and you want to
request keys, you'll notice that
the simple API keys are
available for server
or browser.
When you create a simple API
key, you can actually block
the IP addresses that are
allowed when making API calls
from your application.
So you can say, only requests
should be accepted from the
following IP addresses.
That is if you're dealing
with a server key.
If you're dealing with a browser
key, you can actually
block HTTP referers.
So API keys always allow
you to block IP
addresses or HTTP referers.
If you're using calls that fetch
end-user data, you need
a client ID, which we learned
how to obtain
in last week's webinar.
A client ID doesn't allow you,
by itself, to do that IP
blocking or those HTTP
referer blocking.
And you can do that by
adding an API key.
So when you send both an API
key and a client ID in the
same call, you get the benefits
of using OAuth 2.0
from the client ID plus the
ability to do HTTP referer
blocking and IP blocking
from an API key.
Back to our questions.
The next question states, "How
are client IDs and API keys
different?" I just covered this,
but I think it's worth
mentioning it again.
Client IDs are used when you're
making API calls that
fetch end-user data and will
allow you to build an
application that accesses the
data from an end user without
requiring their password.
For example, a call to the
Google+ API to fetch the posts
for the user who's logged in or
a call to the calendar API
to fetch an end user's
calendars or tasks.
Simple API keys are used when
such API calls do not fetch
end-user data.
An example is the URL
Shortener API.
You can make a call to the URL
Shortener API without a user
ever being logged in.
Another example is the
Translate API.
It works the same.
You can make a call to the
Translate API to do a
straight-up translation
without a user
being logged in.
That is the fundamental
difference between a client ID
and an API key.
There's more questions coming.
Here's one that says, "Can
I make anonymous
calls to Google APIs?
The talk seems to indicate that
this is not possible.
Why?" You'll recall in our last
week's webinar that I
mentioned that when you make API
calls to Google, with very
few exceptions, you need to
pass your credentials that
identify your application when
making these API calls.
This is good for you, the
developer of an application.
This is good for your users.
This is good for Google.
This is good for everyone.
In general, when you pass
credentials, you're
identifying your application
with Google, which will allow
you to manage quota
more effectively.
It will allow you to manage
your user more
effectively, as well.
For example, you can identify
end users who are making
inappropriate use of your
application and who are
consuming all of your quota.
Remember, when you make
API calls, you have a
limited set of quota.
You don't want a few end users
from consuming all of it.
When you pass credentials, this
allows you to identify
both end users and the
application that is making
those calls.
So it's a good practice--
and in many cases required
by Google--
to pass those credentials.
The next question is, "Where do
I learn the details about
the OAuth 2.0 protocol?" You'll
recall in the webinar
that we did a very brief
summary of OAuth 2.0.
And there are lots of
details that can be
covered about OAuth 2.0.
It is not a simple protocol
to understand.
And there's an abundance of
materials on the web to learn
about OAuth 2.0.
Google has extensive OAuth
2.0 documentation.
I provided a link to that
documentation in last week's
webinar, so I suggest you
go and check it out.
There's also a talk on Google
I/O, which will be available
on YouTube, that covers all the
details about OAuth 2.0,
with examples on how to use it
to build your applications,
and actually will walk you
through sample code.
So that would be a very good
resource to check out.
For the documentation--
if I can show you--
the Google developer site has
a page on OAuth 2.0 that not
only will walk you through the
protocol, but will also walk
you through all the scenarios
that exist for OAuth 2.0, such
as using OAuth 2.0 for login,
using OAuth 2.0 for web server
applications, for client-side
applications or JavaScript, or
for installed applications that
run on mobile devices or
other installed applications.
So this page walks you through
the flow in every case.
I just need to remind you, as I
did in last week's webinar,
that if you're using the client
libraries for Google
APIs, that all the details for
OAuth are handled for you.
But it's always good
to know what's
happening behind the scenes.
Back to our questions.
The next question states, "Why
aren't APIs such as YouTube or
Maps showing up in the APIs
Explorer?" You'll recall from
last week's webinar that the
APIs Explorer is a user
interface that will show you a
directory style of Google APIs
and all the methods in them.
And that there's a number of
APIs that show up there.
But as the person who asked this
question noticed, there
are APIs that are missing
from that list,
such as Maps or YouTube.
The APIs that you see in the
APIs Explorer are the APIs
that work with Google's
Discovery Service.
Google is working to add
Discovery Service
for all of its APIs.
And we're making
great progress.
So hopefully, there will come
a day when all of Google's
APIs will show in
this directory.
So today, the support is limited
to the ones you see in
the APIs Explorer.
The next question states, "What
if I do not want to use
a Google Client Library?
What am I missing?" You are not
required to use a Google
Client Library when you're
making an API call.
There's also the possibility
that you're working with a
programming language that Google
doesn't have a client
library for yet.
In both cases, if you're not
using a Google Client Library,
you'll be missing on some
important features that are
designed to make your
life easier.
The most important one
is support for OAuth.
There's client libraries for
nine different programming
languages available
for Google.
And all of them implement
the OAuth steps for you.
If you recall from last week's
webinar, the OAuth steps are a
series of exchanges of API
calls to Google's OAuth
endpoints for access tokens
or refresh tokens.
All of those details are handled
for you in a secure
way by the Google Client
Libraries.
Another thing that the Google
Client Libraries do is that
they format and can access the
resources available for an API
automatically.
So when you use the client
library, you're literally
ready to call that
API in seconds.
They are also considered more
secure because the code has
been built using the
best practices for
calling Google APIs.
So we strongly encourage
you to use
Google Client Libraries.
And if there's a language that
you need to use that we're
missing, let us know.
And that would conclude the
questions that you have asked
about last week's webinar.
You can use this moderator
to keep them coming.
And I thank you very much for
submitting your questions.